astralis the once greatest roster in the
world is now at Rock Bottom they have
failed to qualify for CS Go's final
major so how exactly did this happen and
what's next for them
before we get into the video I want to
let you all know that we've partnered
with Qualcomm Technologies and the team
over at Snapdragon Elite Gaming to
explore the world of mobile Esports our
latest worth episode explores the story
of Bobby and OG two of the best brawl
Stars players in the world but before
they teamed up they truly hated one
another they had to overcome their
differences to prove that the greatest
of enemies can become the perfect team
check out the episode using the link
below over the weekend the qualifiers
for the blast Paris major came to a
close and we now finally have the 24
teams that will be participating in CS
Go's final raw but it wouldn't be CS if
there wasn't drama surrounding the
entire RMR there was Loba and Nico
getting into a ridiculous argument on
Twitter and of course nbk and Kenny s
falling just short of being able to play
at the final major at home oh and of
course we had two of the best teams in
the world who were just in the pro
league Grand finals together having to
Duke it out in a last chance qualifier
for the final spot of csgo's final major
Cloud9 this is Do or Die
raindrops back behind the smoke the
rotation and the flank's even coming in
but
absolutely nothing on the path to Paris
other than misery now although C9 didn't
make it and the prospect of phase even
being in this situation is pretty wild
most of the conversations in the
aftermath of the RMR surround strollers
despite a pretty lights out performance
from their star offer device astralis
failed to get the wins they needed and
won't be attending Paris not only will
this be their second absence from a
major in a row but they're going to be
missing CS Go's final major
piece of History the result has sparked
a ton of questions about what the roster
should do not only in the future but
right now but to better understand the
gravity of this entire situation we have
to go back to last October despite the
devastating split mental health breaks
and plenty of controversies device Glade
and zipnics were finally reunited they
were still missing two of their core
members but they had their star Opera
back and a chance to finally turn things
around unfortunately things didn't go
that way event after event astralis
failed to post any noteworthy results
except it wasn't due to device shaking
off the rust like many people including
myself predicted in fact device was
playing like he hadn't skipped a beat
what tricked it to them last round it's
gonna further funnel them out fully
blind devices
with the deagle spam goes away skinny
cover to play behind but still device
doing it not even an off-needed device
four kills in times and cleared by jabby
but he does his jobs the exact same time
it would have been kind of worth it but
the this is starting to feel a bit
awkward that is one hell of a shot such
a gap device he's gonna keep on going
walks right into bit and sends him to an
early grave every tournament ended up
being the same story device and blame
math would play their asses off but it
wouldn't be enough to carry the team to
Victory and digging deeper than ever
Australis again oh again for the device
two in the round this time not a big
enough multi-kill and it's left onto
Buzz 1v3 The Last Hope for astralis
liquid the tides washing over them as
they take this 2-0 team liquid knockout
astralis and with the announcement of
CS2 and the fact that Paris would be
csgo's last major astralis and device
had one last shot to prove they had What
it Took but once again despite device
playing his heart out astralis couldn't
get it done to make matters worse they
lost to nip which is not only device's
last team but config's new home after
his contract was terminated with
astralis he's been struggling to get up
towards tall Rock and confident gonna be
tested he drops the bomb this raft also
go by the wayside how does claven sit
left all alone the old God of astralis
to keep their dreams alive at nib are
two kills away from knocking them out
make that just one and it's glaive the
igl who needs a lead from the front a
legendary team legendary players a
legendary organization but they will not
even make challenges here at Paris the
final CS go major so astralis the
four-time major winning team won't be
attending CS Go's final major and to say
that device was devastated would be an
understatement I mean after the loss he
pretty much just sat in his chair facing
the wall for God knows how long
Devastation I think you could say for
astralis who had been trying to reform
and refine their form in the last couple
of years but it's it's very hard to
reach the heights that once was I feel
like it's especially disappointing for
device who has put on an incredible
tournament as an individual player in
the aftermath of the loss there were a
ton of reactions from the community of
course plenty of people pointed out
devices Stellar performance but a lot of
people wanted to dig deeper pin pointed
out that despite having a massive lead
in opening kills astralis were still
losing round after round which
potentially calls into question their
ability to call mid-round analyst y k
had even more Choice words for the
Danish orc specifically calling out the
fact that members of the astralis
coaching staff are cheaters this is in
reference to the fact that their coach
Castle has a five major ban and was
unable to coach the team hundon their
new analyst was also unable to step in
as coach because he notoriously has that
exact same band as a result astralis
director of sports had to step in and
Coach the team and well obviously that
didn't go too well now we could sit here
all day and point fingers but there are
some real questions regarding the orange
future that they need to answer
specifically regarding device ever since
rejoining the team device has been
performing well above expectations and
with little to no support time and time
again I think it's fair to say that
maybe he should find a new home sure
they can always rebuild the team around
him and blame F but that comes with its
own complication unless zip and Clay
voluntarily leave how will device feel
playing on the team without them more
importantly it's become clear that
astralis as an org is just completely
lost every decision they make just seems
questionable and maybe it's best with
that baggage for device to just start
fresh the question on everyone's mind is
where would that be now from the outside
looking in you might see a talented
handsome absolutely cracked person-like
device and think man as long as he
speaks the language this guy can go
anywhere and although that is somewhat
true it is more complicated than that
you see device is an opera and as good
as he is offers are typically the star
players of their respective team so that
already eliminates a ton of top tier
rosters next to that unless device
personally takes a pay cut but he's
pretty inexpensive so for a device to
find his forever home the team is not
only going to need an offer but have a
metric ton of money so
hypothesizing on where he might go is a
bit of a crap shoot now although
astralis won't be attending the final
major CS go isn't done yet there are
still plenty of other events for the
team to participate in and since they're
already making changes to the lineup it
seems like astralis is attempting to
ride this out until the wheels fall
off question is will they be doing it
with device and for the man himself how
do you keep your focus knowing that you
won't be attending the final major of
the game that you owe your life to
ask me where he's going a lot of people
on Twitter about 60 of them seem
convinced that it's going to be liquid
they don't believe in the OC Supremacy
and it's possible speaks English they
all speak English I love the cope but I
think it's way too early yeah too early
to cope that hard